all right hello everyone how you guys
doing I hope you guys are having a
wonderful day so today's episode will be
something a little different this is
something I haven't uploaded in a while
which is the hourlong merching challenge
today in honor of the Super Bowl we will
be doing a aerial based theme such as
ranging and whatnot based on the
Atlantis Falcons offense and their
amazing passing game so we're going to
be going off of that and I'm going to be
merching stuff like throwing knives
darts bolts and all that stuff for an
hour so we're going to see how much we
can make off of that but first we do
have a giveway to address in GE tracker
so I'm going to go over there now and
pick a winner this was from a few videos
ago and it is a month membership to the
site so we're going to go pick the
winner for that all right so as you guys
can see over here we have 45 comments so
I'm going to go ahead and go to
random.org right now all right so now
that we are over here we're going to do
a number one through 45 and boom comment
number five we'll go from the probably
from the beginning that would make the
most sense so I'm going to go newest
first and then scroll all the way to the
end all right so I was the first comment
then we go up four so one two 3 4 and uh
there we go so National is the winner of
that so we'll go ahead and just get that
out of the way so on top of that I do
have something else I'd like to talk
about all right so on to another
giveaway that I'm going to do this one's
going to be sponsored by myself and it
was a Super Bowl base giveaway um
problem is is since I'm at my dad this
video isn't going to upload fast enough
so I do have to change the rules for
this so I originally had out a tweet
that was if the Falcons win I'll give
away a bond now I think this video is
probably going to go up like mid thing
so it's not going to be as hype so I'm
just going to have a tweet out that if
the Falcons win I'll still give away a
bond or if the Patriots win I'll have
five items in my inventory of 10 mil
value and if you are able to guess one
of them you get that item if you if you
miss you will not get anything and
that's how we'll do that so that one's a
little bit more risk but still the same
overall value really so go ahead go hit
up the Twitter it'll be in the link in
the description down below just make
sure you retweet that tweet and follow
the uh Twitter account to be entered but
other than that let's get on into the
video I really like this idea so if you
guys enjoy the video at any time make
sure to leave a like but we're going to
go ahead we have 100 Mil we have an hour
you don't need 100 Mil this is going to
be way overkill on that but I'm going to
go ahead find what items I think will
work and we'll get the hour started all
right so I've went ahead and looked at a
little bit of items that I want to go
ahead and do so there we go we got the
timer going or I guess up we're get it
GL going now so there you go 59 minutes
56 seconds we have some margins that I
really like right now so let's go ahead
and look at them right now dragon javs
have about a 40 GP margin that's
perfectly fine with me I'm just going to
go ahead and put in an absurd amount
that I know I won't be able to buy but
it'll cover what I need to cover from
there Rune Javelin heads um they don't
have much of a margin now however I
think that the one that I bought was
just a little overpriced so I'm going to
go ahead and put in an offer for like
3,000 of those as well from there we go
back over and as you guys can see Dragon
Javelin heads that's an unrealistic
margin because no one's going to mass
buy him for 2.5k there's no point you'd
lose a ton of money making these people
obviously wait it out so I'm going to go
ahead throw in an offer for a lot of
these and up it by 1gp then on top of
that we have a couple things that I
really don't I haven't told people about
this one in particular but Rune darts
these have a 14 GP margin which is
perfectly fine with me I'll go ahead and
throw in an offer for like 15K I don't
know exactly what the um overall or
overall amount per hour that you can buy
is but we'll try that then on top of
that as you guys can see see Rune darts
P are significantly lower so I'm going
to see how many I can buy for this price
right now just straight off the bat cuz
I know I'd make a lot of money with this
so one ahead cannot buy any or I bought
71 I guess it's something but that's not
really what I want to see I'm going to
go ahead and do more but the thing is is
that you can unclean these and by doing
so I'm going to be making about 140 GP
per one that cells now about 2 to 3,000
of these are bought and sold in hour so
we can pretty much guarantee a decent
amount of money to be made right there
so I'm going to go ahead up it by a
couple GP from what I previously saw and
just throw in a decent offer for a ton
of those from there I'm going to go
ahead find a few different items and
we'll come back when it's all done all
right so there we go the rest has been
done I do have to buy some Dragon bolts
so Dragon bolts have a 15 GP margin as
you guys just saw there for a second on
top of that as you guys could have saw
the Run KN have around a 28 GP margin so
that's fine by me and then broad bolts
also have an 11 GP margin which is isn't
bad at all considering I think there'll
be a pretty fast merge which seems to be
confirmed by the fact that I've already
bought 5.5k so not too bad there uh
dragon javs and Rune javs are starting
to go through which is really nice but
uh we'll let these things kind of do
their thing and we'll be back here in a
few all right so a little while in the
Rune darts are going all right got about
a 30 GP margin on those so I bought
about 7,000 so hopefully that's about
200k we can make there uh the Run darts
P we got a decent amount coming in
hopefully we can make a 100K is or so
off of what we've gotten so far um we've
got about 400 but there's 150 GP margin
so that's not bad I'm hoping I can get
more of those the Rune Javelin heads
were all right they had a decent margin
but hoping I can sell those off and
right now I've kind of switched back on
over well not back on over but for the
first time over to Dragon darks and
dragon Dart tips because I realized
these things have incredible margins
like 30 to 40 GP per one and they are
bought and sold constantly so now that
we are over onto that hopefully we can
start making a little bit more money the
one problem that I'm having obviously as
you guys can see is my GE is filled and
I have stuff that I cannot sell off so
we might have to take a little bit of
time out of this at the end to sell them
off while I wait and there we go so the
broad bolts sold off which is real nice
U I'm going to go ahead and collect
everything that we have so as you guys
can see we have a ton of Rune darts over
here and not many are selling on so I'm
going to go ahead and throw all of these
in for 11 181 and hopefully those will
sell with due time so that'll be a
pretty decent merch on top of that going
to go ahead and sell off the dragon Dart
tips which which we are getting a decent
amount of these are going to be about a
70 GP merch which would be really nice
considering we just had some more sell
on so that'll be a good 35k or so so
we're going to go ahead and try to sell
these on as well all right so we are
closing in on the 15minute Mark I'm
going to go ahead and just start to get
things ready to sell these things are
just being so annoying like the javelin
heads they say that there's a decent
amount bought and sold they just happen
I guess I would imagine just to drop
while I happen to do this which is
pretty annoying but we do what we can um
the Rune darts are selling we actually
had about four to 45,000 sell and uh
some more are buying the Run darts P are
buying which is really good that's where
I was hoping I can make a lot of money
and right now it's looking like I can
make about 170k off of those so that's
really nice and uh yeah just checking
out everything right now there we go so
uh hit a big low Mark here all of the
Rune darts have sold on so we were able
to make about 25 GP off of all of them I
think that was around 10K almost so yeah
that's that's almost a 250k margin I
mean realistically closer to 200k but we
have another 2,000 bought here we also
have well none left here but we've
boughten 1.3k which we're going to make
a decent amount off of now so I'm going
to show you guys how I'm going to go
about doing this all you need to do to
take poson off of anything in the game
is just go ahead and have a cleaning
cloth and from there all you have to do
is use cleaning cloth on the Rune darts
I believe I just wore them as I did just
go ahead and clean them and then boom
Rune darts that's why I don't understand
why they're so low so this is something
that's definitely pretty helpful if you
guys have never seen this before but
going to be able to sell these on for
one 181
now so should be able to make some
decent money there other than that we
don't have a whole lot going on uh just
a couple Dragon darts we were able to
sell off some and uh yeah going to have
to sell these off whenever I get space
so we're closing down the end I'm going
to go ahead and just get ready and then
start to sell off all this when the time
comes there we go that's the end I'm
going to stop this timer God every time
I just feel the need to show you guys
the end of the timer but I literally it
destroys my ears so there we go I'm
going to collect everything that we got
and uh just take out all the offers and
then we'll go ahead and sell off
everything and see how much we've made I
also kind of want you guys to keep into
consideration this won't be the most
that I've ever made by any means those
are some of the highest margin videos
and stuff like that this is bit of more
of a category and show you guys how to
flip so let's go ahead I'll sell them
off and we'll see how much we made this
episode all right so here we go I had to
kind of Rush and sell the rest of this
just cuz I wanted to get this all done
before the Super Bowl starts up and I
can get this video uploaded and just
kind of chilling before we actually get
on into the festivi so going to go ahead
and sell off these last few darts and we
are done so I made a ton of money though
let me tell you off of these Dragon Dart
tips I sold on a ton for like I think
what was about 100 GP profit and I was
selling on a some for around here I did
lose money on the final 400 just cuz I
want to get this done but we're going to
go ahead and collect I don't even know
if we made a meil we made a mill which
is actually really good I'm really happy
about that because that means we at
least you know made a decent
money-making method out of just a crazy
kind of like just just a random category
of things emerge so if we go ahead and
check out we uh yeah we made 1 mil 50k
so I'm really glad that we were able to
make that if you guys enjoyed the video
make sure to leave a like if you guys
want to be entered into the giveaway
make sure to hit up the Twitter that's
in the description down below as I've
said before you guys can comment and
tell me whatever you want to tell me
obviously you're going to do that either
way uh you can add me in game you know
large exp lamp small exp lamp they're
the same also join the clan chat of7
helpers but with that being said hope
you guys have a wonderful day and peace
[Music]
d